on you about and we really looked at the  negative consequences of the the  constant mobile connection social media  it's all just fake metrics of popularity  like how many people like me like really  like how many people hearted my photo  like and which was fake to begin with so  you know and and this is like you know  our children yes are being taught that  these vanity metrics are important and  that to me is a dangerous road to tread  because I don't personally see how you  could look at that in a constructive way  in the long term right oh the vanity  metrics of likes is going to somehow  elevate human consciousness and make us  better no but if we